[Musique]
voilà des plus que ce truc est forcé
leur à sortir
mais là
ciblant le mégot
tels sont des lacs
bumblebee au cinéma le
6 décembre toi tu quoi qu'il en soit tu
viens ok c'est rien ou quoi moi j'étais
charlie johnson évier 18 ans aujourd'hui
et ouais c'est mon ami aujourd'hui
comment tu t'appelles date d'abandon ou
que tu le connais pas tu pour d'autres
comme un petit pourtant demain
[Musique]
un peu belge fit appeler comme ça
bumblebee
et puis ça va avec des carrosseries
bumblebee au cinéma le 26 décembre
alors les gens peuvent être aussi bête
que méchant avec ceux qui ne comprennent
pas si on te trouveras t'enfermer dans
un labo quelques balles et ce sera pas
rigolo crois moi la seule personne qui
ait le droit de te voir c'est moi ok on
s'entraîne tpr est quelqu'un d'autre que
moi harry qu'est ce que tu fais génial
parfait revient bon alors on dit qu'on
est ensemble ok on roule tranquille et
voilà que projet car il cache toi
[Musique]
t'es sérieux bémol bis au cinéma le 26
décembre à travailler aujourd'hui quoi
toi j'ai pas quelqu'un qui peut aider au
kit mois
comme albi tu dois protéger la terre et
ses habitants
la seule personne qui doit te voir c'est
moi non